we want this book the bankers new
clothes because we became very concerned
about the fact that the banking system
is still very dangerous and very fragile
and there it hasn't been fixed even
though we knew and we already saw that
it can cause a lot of damage to the rest
of the economy banks and financial
institutions are by far the most
indebted entities in the economy there
is no industry that comes even near the
indebtedness of the banks they basically
are similar to our home owner who paid
almost no down payment to get a big
mansion that's what they're like
obviously such a bore as many have seen
can go underwater pretty easily
the large institutions have no
comparison in the economy in size and
complexity if this system starts
cracking what we might discover is what
Ireland discovered or what Iceland
discovered that they are almost too big
to save that they can really take down
economies with them the system can be
fixed first and foremost by realizing
that there is nothing that special about
banks every industry is special and
banks have their own things that they do
but some would have you believed that
banks are so special that nothing that
other firms or other businesses
experience or the forces that they have
to deal with applies to banks that they
live in their own universe that they
make up their own rules there are things
that are different about banks but the
key to making banking healthier is to
apply some of the same principles or
bring them back into the same type of
economic considerations and economic
costs that the rest of the world lives
by
the banks would have you believe that if
we try to make them safer that somehow
that would interfere with what they can
do the first thing to realize is that's
just false that is a false statement and
misleading in a self-serving assertion
the banks can be a lot safer and yet
there will if anything work better for
the rest of the economy the reason that
people need to read this book is because
this is not gonna change unless more
people know what's going on understand
the issues a little bit better which we
hope to have educated people on and are
able to press those in charge to be more
accountable